okay so in this video we're gonna go
over some of the basics on what atoms
are and the periodic table of elements
so let's go ahead and get started all
right so what is an atom an atom by
definition is simply the smallest unit
of all matter matter makes up pretty
much everything in our known universe so
atoms make up our universe and so
there's three main parts to an atom and
two of those parts are in the nucleus
there is a positively charged part of
proton and there is a part with a zero
charge or a neutral charge and this is
called a neutron so in the picture the
nucleus is represented by the blue and
red spheres all clustered together
spinning around the nucleus we have the
electrons and they orbit the nucleus and
what's called the electron cloud we'll
go into more detail on that in a little
bit but for now I want you to know that
electrons have a negative electrical
charge when it comes to their numbers
the numbers of protons and the numbers
of electrons are usually equal in number
we're going to learn some examples later
in this video where they are not equal
but it's a general rule there is that
protons and electrons usually have the
same number of one another
when you look at this periodic table of
elements you've seen this before I'm
sure the periodic table of elements is a
collection of elements that are known to
exist so how is an element different
from an atom while an element like it
says is a substance made from only one
type of atom picture a big sheet of
aluminum let's say you wanted to cover
some food with a big sheet of aluminum
so you rip off maybe a two-foot long
strip of aluminum
well that two-foot long strip of
aluminum foil is simply made from one
element it's made from the element
called aluminum but in that two-foot
long strip there are billions and
billions and trillions and trillions of
individual aluminum atoms so I hope that
kind of clarifies the difference between
an element and an atom
well what about reading the periodic
table you know you can see the red the
black box blinking on carbon let's zoom
on in and take a look at the square of
carbon on the periodic table when we do
we see that there is the number 6 and
the number 12 well let's figure out what
these numbers are the smaller number by
the way this kind of drives me nuts
there's really no standard periodic
table format sometimes the small numbers
on top sometimes the small numbers on
the bottom sometimes the small numbers
in the corner so that's kind of annoying
but the small number is what we call the
atomic number by definition the atomic
number is the number of protons that the
atom will contain so right now I know
that carbon has 6 protons well think
about what we said a moment ago usually
the number of protons is the same as the
number of electrons so I also now know
that carbon has 6 electrons well the
bigger number is what is called the
atomic mass or the atomic weight and by
definition the atomic mass is the
combined amount the combined number of
protons and neutrons that are packed
inside the nucleus when you add up the
protons and neutrons you get the mass of
the atom if you're wondering well why
don't we add the electrons it seems
silly to weigh something and ignore one
of the three parts why don't we add the
electrons to the mass well like it says
in the notes the electrons are just way
too small to really have much of an
impact on the mass a good analogy is
let's say you were to weigh yourself
before and after receiving a haircut
yeah your hair has some weight to it
your hair has mass to it but if you
weigh yourself before a haircut and you
weigh yourself after a haircut the
weight of your hair is so small compared
to the rest of your body it's not really
gonna register on the scale the same
with electrons they're just so small
they don't really register they're so
small they don't really add very much to
the mass
of an atom so when we look at the
protons neutrons and electrons of carbon
I hope you can see there's six protons
six electrons and six neutrons but let's
go through this in a little more detail
they're not always going to be the same
number repeated three times let's show
you how we came up with these numbers
so let's use another example be e stands
for beryllium well if I were to give you
a moment to figure out protons electrons
and neutrons hopefully you can do that
on your own pause the video if you want
to try it on your own I'm gonna go over
the answers in three two one so right
now the number on top of the four that's
the atomic number that tells me the
number of protons so right now I know
beryllium has four protons remember the
atomic number is the number of protons
by definition but the proton number is
usually equal to the electron number so
I now know that beryllium also has four
electrons what about the nine and the
bottom that is the atomic mass by
definition that is the number of protons
plus neutrons well in this case protons
plus neutrons equals nine so earlier I
know that there is four protons plus how
many number of neutrons equals nine four
plus what number equals nine well
there's your answer of five so that's
how you can figure out from the periodic
table protons electrons and neutrons
let's try one more
so if we were in class I would give you
a minute to discuss these questions with
your neighbor but pause the video if you
want to try them and I'm gonna go over
the answers in three two one
so what is the atomic mass of chlorine I
kind of mixed up the order of these to
kind of see if you were paying attention
so when I put the labels up here the
small number is the atomic number the
larger number is the atomic mass so to
answer question a the atomic mass is 35
question B the atomic number is always
the smaller number that's 17 questions
see how many electrons does chlorine
contain well I hope you know that 17
because the electron number is usually
the same as the proton number letter D
how many protons is chlorine contain
well by definition that's the atomic
number number of protons and the last
one how many new trends does chlorine
contain I know there are 17 protons plus
how many neutrons equals 35 17 plus what
mystery number equals 35 the answer is
18
okay let's get back to discussing atoms
now we kind of breezed over the electron
cloud I want to go into more detail so
electrons orbit the nucleus and what are
known as energy levels or electron
levels and that's what you see in this
picture right here you see two electrons
orbiting the nucleus well the first
level the first level we define as the
level that's closest to the nucleus the
first level the first energy level can
actually only hold two electrons and
then it's full and when inner let when a
level is full we also say that that
level is stable so the picture that I've
drawn right now this is actually helium
helium only has two total electrons
those two total electrons that helium
has will be orbiting in the first energy
level helium doesn't even have a second
level it doesn't even have a third level
so moving on to the second level
when we look at the second level the
second level can can hold and be stable
with with a total of eight electrons if
it has fewer than eight electrons then
that particular atom is not stable and
that's going to be an important part of
this video going forward in a few
moments but notice in the animation that
the second level can hold a total of
eight electrons with a total of eight it
is said to be stable the picture that
you see by the way happens to be the the
atom of neon neon has a total of 10
electrons two electrons in level one
eight electrons in level two two plus
heat adds up to the ten electrons that
neon has what about that third level
so the third level the third level can
also hold eight electrons and if an atom
has eight electrons it is said to be
stable it is said to have a full third
electron level and so the picture by the
way is showing argon-argon has a total
of count them up two electrons in the
first level eight electrons in the
second level eight electrons in the
third level two eight and eight that
adds up to 18 total electrons and so
atoms as we said throughout this this
slide right here atoms are said to be
stable when their outermost level is
full full of electrons well what happens
if they're not full of electrons that's
what I want to focus on next
so here is a atom of carbon carbon has
the atomic number of six and the atomic
mass of 12 number that six tells me the
definition of the atomic number which
means six protons but if it has six
protons also you is gonna have six
electrons so let me draw the six
electrons I can add two electrons in
level number one but that's it that's
all level number one can hold and then
the remaining four electrons go in level
number two so carbon doesn't even have a
third electron level if I were to ask
you is carbon a stable atom I hope you
would know the answer to that the answer
is no carbon is not a stable atom the
second level only has four electrons it
needs four more it needs to have a total
of eight to be full and stable so what
do atoms do when they're not full and
stable
that's what again this video the rest of
this video is going to is going to
address
so what do atoms do when they're not
stable they form molecules molecule is
our two or more atoms held together by a
chemical bond and as I just mentioned
molecules are gonna form when atoms are
not stable not stable means they don't
have a full complete set of electrons
well you may know from middle school
that there's really two main types of
chemical bonds so the first one I want
to mention are called covalent bonds and
covalent bonds begin by definition it's
a chemical bond where atoms are gonna be
sharing electrons with one another they
share the limited amount of electrons
that they each possess that way they all
can become stable a great example of
this is the molecule that we breathe
called
oxygen in the in the formula for oxygen
is o2 that means there's two oxygen
atoms bonded together through what's
called a covalent bond and that's what
we breathe that's what plants give off
during photosynthesis that's what we
breathe to keep us alive so oxygen that
we breathe is a molecule made from two
atoms of individual oxygen oxygen atoms
so let's look at an oxygen atom so in
the periodic table I see the atomic
number of eight that means it has eight
protons that also means that it has
eight electrons so let me draw the eight
electrons I can put two electrons in
level number one and I can put the
remaining six electrons in level number
two so there's a problem there oxygen by
itself the oxygen atom is not stable it
needs a total of two more electrons so
why is oxygen unstable because it only
has six electrons in its outer level it
needs a total of two more for a total of
eight so what's gonna happen well in a
moment I'll show you an animation where
oxygen atom where one oxygen atom will
actually share electrons with a
neighboring oxygen atom so two oxygen
atoms will share the limited supply of
electrons that they each have
and the end result what happens when
they do this they're both going to
become stable they're gonna form what's
called a covalent bonded molecule let's
show you this animation
so here we have two atoms of oxygen one
in green one in red well let's add the
electrons to the oxygen in red I know it
has a total of eight so I can put two
electrons in the first level and that
leaves six electrons left over in level
number two
so both oxygens by themselves are not
stable but watch what they do they bond
with one another they're a lot their
electron levels overlap like this now
you know let me put those notes back up
from a moment ago just so we can have
that to reference so like it says what
happens
well oxygen atoms are gonna share two
electrons with a neighboring oxygen atom
and when they do the end result both are
gonna end with eight electrons look at
the oxygen in green
it's got it six in green and then it's
got two in red for a total of eight look
at the oxygen in red it's got six in red
in its outer level but it also has two
in green in the outer level for a total
of eight they both become
and so what you actually see and in this
animation I only animated those four
electrons in motion but in reality all
the electrons are in motion I just
didn't want to add all the electrons in
motion I thought that would be too much
clutter so what you have is the sharing
of electrons right here so the electrons
kind of like a figure 8 style will zoom
back and forth between the two oxygen
atoms you might often see this
diagrammed like this picture right here
the two dashes represent chemical bonds
this is an example of a double bond two
dashes means a double bond because
they're the two atoms are sharing two
pairs of electrons so let's go back to
molecules so there's two main types of
bonds one we just mentioned was called a
covalent bond the next is called an
ionic bond and this is a chemical bond
where electrons are either gained or
lost there's no sharing one atom will
gain electrons another atom is gonna
lose electrons and when that happens
this is what the pictures imply and when
that happens the two atoms are gonna be
held together by magnetism good
old-fashioned magnetic attraction you
know when you first played with magnets
when you're a four-year-old kid you were
just fascinated with them when you put
the positive end of one magnet next to
the negative end of another magnet they
stuck and they held together and so
that's magnetism the negative charge is
can is attracted to the positive charge
so what's gonna cause this to happen
well the cause of this it says it says
one atom is gonna steal an electron or
maybe more than one electron one atom is
gonna steal an electron from another and
that's gonna create what's called an ion
an ion is an atom that has either a
positive charge or an ion can be an atom
that has a negative charge and so an
example of this is when sodium and
chlorine bond together they form
something called sodium chloride you
know sodium chloride by its more common
name
salt salt is a great example of a
molecule made from an ionic bond let's
go ahead and go through an example of
this so here we have sodium in red
chlorine and blue and if we look at the
the sodium na is sodium we look at the
periodic table Square of sodium I see
the number 11 on top that tells me it
has 11 protons so let me fill in this
table right now sodium has 11 positively
charged protons I also know it has 11
electrons so 11 negatively charged
electrons watch this the net charge is
zero if you're wondering what do I mean
by net charge when you when you counter
the protons and electrons you know if
you're given eleven dollars but then you
go and spend eleven dollars your net
your net worth is zero you have no money
and so eleven positive protons are
balanced out by eleven negative
electrons that's what we mean by the net
charge of being zero you know let me
draw those eleven electrons in the
picture on top I can put two electrons
in the first level of sodium I can put
eight electrons in the second level of
sodium now sodium only has total of
eleven that means there's only one
electron in sodium's outside level so I
hope you see why sodium is unstable
you know let's focus our attention now
on chlorine here's the periodic table
Square of chlorine and chlorine has the
atomic number of 17 that means it has 17
positively charged protons remember the
proton number is usually equal to the
electron number so there means it has 17
negatively charged electrons for a net
charge of zero just like last time the
17 positives are canceled out by the 17
negatives for a net charge of zero well
chlorine has 17 electrons let me draw
them I can put two of the electrons in
level number one that means 15 are left
over well I can't put all 15 in level
number two but I can
eight and level number two that leaves a
total of seven left over yes all seven
can go in level three remember level
three can carry up to eight so right now
I hope you see that chlorine is also
unstable but here's where an ionic bond
occurs watch what happens the definition
of an ionic bond is when one atom steals
an electron from another chlorine is
gonna steal an electron from sodium and
when it does sodium is gonna become
positively charged and also will become
stable because all its electron levels
are filled it doesn't even have a third
level anymore chlorine is gonna become
negatively charged but it also is going
to become stable when you look at the
core the electron levels of chlorine
they're all filled and watch what
happens now because of magnetism sodium
is positively charged chlorine is
negatively charged they're gonna bond
they're gonna stick together and form up
what's called a molecule sodium chloride
also called salt well we have to kind of
change our table now because of the
changing of that electron so after they
bond the numbers are a little different
first of all notice how the proton
numbers don't change the only thing that
was taken was an electron sodium doesn't
have 11 electrons anymore count up the
count up sodium's electrons it only has
10 it lost an electron to chlorine
chlorine used to have 17 electrons but
it just took one from sodium so it had
17 plus the one it took from sodium for
total of 18 now when you look at the net
charge you can see why sodium has a
positive charge it has more protons you
can see why chlorine has a negative
charge it has more electrons that's what
causes them to bond that's what that's
that magnetic attraction that I
mentioned
so there you go there's a quick overview
of atoms in the periodic table if you're
in my biology class pause the video and
try to answer these questions bring them
on a separate sheet of paper I'd be
happy to check them for accuracy good
luck